finanz coaches aus der wirtschaft
seltsam solche schulfremden doch die
achtklässler wundern sich nur kurz denn
was die erzählen ist spannend wie sollen
die schüler später nach dem abitur ihren
eigenen haushalt bestreiten
bei mama bleiben oder auf eigenen beinen
aber dann bitte mit köpfchen natürlich
sie bekommen taschengeld aber wo kommt
geld überhaupt her und das nächste
schicke handy wird das wenn sie 18 sind
wieder papa bezahlen
vorsicht bei einem kredit wie
funktioniert ein kredit überhaupt und
das brutto vom lohn ist das auch das
netto gut dass wir so was in der schule
machen besser fürs leben vorbereitet
werden
also ein bisschen gedanken weil das
leben sollte man schon sich machen aber
jetzt nicht so jeden tag so ja was
mächtig werden was möchte ich alles aus
gehört so ein bisschen hinter im
hinterkopf sollte man es schon alles
behalten
ich versuche gute noten zu haben dass
ich dann nachher studieren kann
das ist dann mit dem geld verdiene
ein haus ein haus ein auto kaufen leute
aus der wirtschaft will dann im terra
und der schule und petra carbon die
klassenlehrerin ist froh darüber leuten
aus der praxis so die erfahrung hören
die schüler viel besser zu ich find halt
schule soll so vieles jetzt können wir
sollen erziehen wir sollen
fachunterricht machen wir sind bitter
aufs leben vorbereiten wir sollen für
die firmvorbereitung er wieder irgendwo
es auch ein studium mal zu ende
und warum wohl ich mir damit die
experten rein
ich bin ja dabei wenn mir was nicht
gefallen würde kann ich ja sofort
reagieren und die kinder haben definitiv
mehr gewinnen externe aus der wirtschaft
hätten offenbar einen alien bonus sagt
bettina wende sonst verkauft die
rüsselsheimerin versicherungen
seit vier jahren ist sie ehrenamtlich
als wirtschafts lehrerin dabei ihr
wissen aus dem beruf gibt sie gern an
kinder weiter gab der ursprung war auch
dass sich sehr viele junge menschen
heutzutage verschulden bevor sie
überhaupt eigentlich fähig werden sich
zu verschulden über handy verträge und
solche sachen
dass man es vermeiden will gehen einfach
ein bisschen an die hand mit geben wie
sie das echte leben aus
doch es gibt auch die sorge finanzcoach
es könnten werben in eigener sache oder
schüler manipulieren
zum beispiel mit markenlogos
versicherungsfrei wende ist von der
allianz aber die schüler erfahren davon
nichts die coaches verpflichten sich
entlang der beutelsbacher konsens zur
hand heißt also nicht die fülle zu
überwältigen irgendwelchen botschaften
kontrovers zu diskutieren
und natürlich auch keine werbung zu
machen steht explizit auch drinnen keine
einzelnen produkte zu nennen
das sind die die kernbestandteile dann
aber natürlich auch die schüler mit
respekt behandeln am ende gibt es eine
urkunde ein eigener haushalt wissen sie
nun kostet sie monatlich 1000 euro
mindestens das hat sie dann doch erstmal
erschreckt zugleich lernten sie aber
auch man kann sich vieles selbst
erarbeiten
allein das ist für den schulleiter ein
gewinn aus der wirtschaft das fehlen
auszubildende
es fehlen fachkräfte und es gibt ja
mittlerweile auch die bündnisse schule
und wirtschaft
es gibt natürlich die praktiker ist
schon seit sehr langer zeit wo wir
schüler in die betriebe schicken es gibt
kooperationen mit betrieben und ich
finde das nicht nur legitim sondern sehr
förderungswürdig werden nun kinder zu
angepassten konsumenten erzogen wie
kritiker fürchten
am ende hängt es wohl davon ab was
eltern und schule ihnen sonst noch so
beibringen